77 year old billionaire Robert Kraft is accused
We’ve all heard that New England Patriots owner
Robert Kraft was caught in a sex trafficking sting.
Women at the spas were lured into the sex trade.
They were women who were from China,
who were forced into sex slavery.
We’re told it happens all the time.
Thousands of children are raped every day.
Sex trafficking, a growing problem.
But that’s not true, says reporter Elizabeth Nolan Brown.
In Robert Kraft’s case:
They had all of these big announcements at first saying
that they had bust up
an international sex trafficking ring,
that these women were being forced there
and they weren’t allowed to leave.
This is not about lonely old man or victimless crimes.
This is about enabling a network of criminals to
traffic women into our country for forced labor and sex.
But now prosecutors concede
there was no sex trafficking.
And that’s typical.
I'd say 99% of the headlines are not true.
Sex trafficking and prostitution
are just sort of used interchangeably.
We're here to rescue people that need to be rescued.
Police routinely claim they rescue women.
They say “we rescued these women” and by rescue
they put them in jail and give them a criminal record.
The victims are the sex workers themselves who are
getting harassed and locked up in cages by the cops.
Agents arresting at least 14 suspects.
Being arrested doesn’t help you.
These women chose to be sex workers.
I wasn't coerced.
It was something that I actively wanted to do.
But the cops call it sex trafficking.
You were trafficked.
Yeah, they call a lot of things trafficking,
the drug trafficking, the immigration trafficking.
Celebrities perpetuate the myth.
Today you can go online and buy a child for sex.
It's as easy as ordering a pizza.
Human trafficking is
the fastest growing illegal business in the world.
If that was the case, cops would be able
to find this all the time,
cops wouldn't be having to
go through these elaborate
doing these elaborate stings.
Florida police spent months
taking down the Robert Kraft spa.
They had Homeland Security involved,
they were following these women around
the grocery stores, watching them buy condoms,
they were going through their trash
and analyzing their trash.
If this was really a situation where these women
were being forced and sexually assaulted
multiple times a day,
the cops just let it happen for months on end?
The women were trafficked.
In case after case, police call the women “sex slaves.”
These women are true victims.
I actually talked to one of the sheriffs
who was interviewed there
the first one, John Urquhart, and he ended up saying,
“Well, you know, I mean maybe they weren't being forced
by whatever, but we're all trafficked by something
and there was money involved,
and then by the end of the investigation they were like,
“Well, I mean, they were pressured because they didn't
know a lot of people and they wanted to make money,”
The implication is,
with the number of men and the number of hours,
that this couldn't have been voluntary.
I read through all the court documents involved in this,
and it actually paints a very, very different story.
The documents, as usual,
made reference to prostitution.
The women apparently were willing.
We wanted to rescue them out of that horrible life.
They are on a moral crusade.
They're doing the right thing.
But all they did was actually go in there,
bust up their place of business,
close it down, and then let the women go.
The cops are not cruel, they, I assume
they want to do the right thing.
Why would they say this stuff?
Cops like working these kinds of cases, I think.
They bring the police good publicity
A major sex trafficking ring busted
And also…
You have a lot of federal money coming at this.
These human trafficking task forces
where the federal government funds
these local cops to do these stings,
and if they call them human trafficking stings,
they get this money.
So much of the anti-prostitution laws that
are being pushed is a combination
of the conservative fetish
for going after people for doing “sex stuff"
and the liberal instinct to help a group of people
that they can't be bothered to understand.
Trafficking is a real problem in every state
in the United States of America.
Right now almost 300,000 American children are at risk.
300,000 children.
300,000
Not just at risk, says this former prosecutor:
300,000 kids a year are raped, sex trafficked,
and pimped in this country.
That 300,000 number
was disavowed.
The lead author of the study, Richard Estes,
now disavows it,
the National Crimes Against Children Center says
do not cite this study.
So many people debunk the study and say
this is just a total bull crap number.
I'd like to tell you a story about a 15-year old girl
Actor Ashton Kutcher even promotes an app
which he claims rescues sex trafficking victims.
We’ve identified and recovered
over 6,000 trafficking victims this year.
Ashton Kutcher has this app….
[ugh]
which he claims recovers victims.
300,000 children are at risk.
Where is he getting these numbers?
If Ashton Kutcher is finding all those victims,
he's not turning them over to police.
Kutcher’s representatives did not respond
to our repeated emails.
When we have these exaggerated numbers,
it forces people to go into this
crazy emergency moral panic mode that
ends up not helping the actual problem that we have.
If it was your daughter there
you would not be saying it’s a victimless crime.
They want to just eradicate all prostitution.
We will not stop until we have stamped out
the menace of human trafficking.
They want this imaginary world where if you take away
you know, a safer option for these women
and everyone will just,
the oldest profession as they call it, will magically stop.
But that's not going to happen.
They are treating the women like a piece of furniture.
The way we try to stop that from happening,
is actually making the problem worse.